ProJared did an oopsie!
James Charles did probably
the biggest oopsie of all time!
And PewDiePie?
No oopsie this week
I'm Glorie Poopie, and you're watching Pew News
[Intro plays]
[Nokia cellphone rings]
PRRRT- PRRRR
[Nokia cellphone rings again]
What's that? PewDiePie DID do an oopsie this week?
DAMMIT!
PewDiePie here.
I'd just like to apologize for my oopsie this week
Don't know where to begin.
I thought the dog from Up was the dog from Pets
[Flashback] When the dog from Pets looks better than the original Sonic
I don't know how this had happened,
and I just want to say how deeply sorrow —
sorrowful I am
I know I'm better than this
Let's get into why everyone clicked on this video
James Charles, biggest oopsie of 2019
James Charles will have a scandal, similar to the one he's had before
James Charles: absolutely not.
bum bum bum bubububu babababa
[laughing]
Oopsie
Doopsie
Woopsie
Poopsie
This is a big one
James Charles going down to 16 million subscribers
And the Internet could not be more thrilled
"Congrats on 15 mil, been here since 16"
[laughs]
James Charles losing —
jESUS LORD ALMIGHTY
1.4 million subscribers!
Breaking records in losing subscribers
faster than anyone has ever gained subscribers
So what happened?
Well...
YouTuber "Tati, Tati, Tati"?
Made a video called "Bye Sister"
A clever play on words
[whispers] Because James Charles's slogan is "Hi Sisters"
And she called it "Bye Sister?"
[Crazy giggling]
The tea!
Glug glug glug glug glug
Now this video is 43 minutes long,
so I did the favour of watching it for you.
You are welcome!
Jesus Christ
Can you not make it anymore less concise?
43 minutes? You expect everyone...
Now people know James Charles already, he's pretty...
I think most people in the beauty community kind of —
Yes, they're really big but
in the beauty community, but James Charles is just one of those figures that kinda...
People know about him at least
And I think that's why this just got so massive
So what did she say? Well...
She starts off by showing how they've been friends for a long time,
and she's been supporting
James Charles for a long time
"James is here to-- uhh, do my Bridal makeup
which is what I am wearing right nooow."
"Ehhm I just wanted to congratulate you on almost a
million on Instagram. I want to say huge
congratulations to James Charles, if you
have not checked his channel out on Youtube..."
Alright we get it
She talks about why this video happened
in beginning like why she's calling out
James Charles. But it's very confusing
unless you know what happened, you're not
going to understand anything of it
"I'm gonna share a lot of it with you, because
I feel at this point that I have to,
because Gabriel Zamora decided to... "
What does that mean?! I don't understand!
Oh God do I have to watch... How many
videos do I have to watch?
"I love him, and I am there for this kid through and through."
So she's been supporting James for a long time
Then she talks about how fame
has changed James Charles
"Fame, power and a fat bank account will change almost anyone.
And if you don't have people that will tell you to your face that you're doing the wrong things, you will change."
And then she finished off by completely
disassociating herself from James Charles
It feels like she feels responsible
for creating this monster that is James Charles
And it makes sense to disassociate with that
"I don't want to be friends with you,
I don't want to be associated with you,
and I need to say that very publicly so that this chapter can just be closed. "
She explains some examples of how she helped James Charles with contracts
and her husband helping him and all this sort of thing
"Um, he didn't have money for the flight or hotel, so I paid for that happily.
But you're family, how can I help you?
My husband would spend hours on the phone looking over contracts, getting him in a better position
So we helped him get into a style haul
back when basically no one wanted to work with him because of his Ebola scandal."
And then finally with I think the most
hard-hitting thing is about
how James Charles kind of used his fame and power
to get straight people into getting with him?
That's sort of his kink it seems like. Okay. Alright.
And she calls out what's problematic about that.
"Literally made me want to vomit. Oh my god, you tried to trick a straight man into thinking he's gay, yet again!
And somehow, you're the victim.
You know, it's really disgusting
to manipulate someone's sexuality
especially when they are still, you know,
emerging into adulthood
and don't quite have everything figured out.
You are using your fame, your power, your money, to play wit   h people's emotions.
You're threatening to ruin them, you're threatening to embarrass them."
[Plays drums on the table]
That's basically the gist of the video.
James Charles, not a good person. I think
there's plenty of reason to dislike him
I mean, we've seen so many strange things about him
As soon as anyone says anything about James Charles, you'll get this tweet saying:
"This is not funny, delete this
immediately or my lawyer will be in contact."
Okay...
Full disclaimer:
I'm not excusing his behavior. I don't think it's right
But with this massive amount of backlash,
he's facing the biggest sub drop
that anyone's ever faced on YouTube
Look at all the controversies that have happened on Youtube
Is this really like... that comparable?
It seems to me like a lot of people respect this 'Tati' figure, at least in the beauty community
And James Charles is already this controversial figure that people aren't really sure about
So for her to make this big stance of disassociating herself from James Charles,
it seems that a lot of people are just latching on to that, just to shit on James Charles
Which I get; it's funny
It's like everyone is like:
[mocking] "HAHA unsubscribe! HAHA!!!"
Because there are a couple things about this that genuinely bothered me when I saw it
Why was this video actually being made?
What caused her to get so upset?
It's not really clear in the video, at least unless you understand what had happened
I looked into it, and the whole thing
makes even less sense!
At least, you know, for an outsider,
I could still misunderstand things about it,
but this is what caused the controversy,
this Instagram post:
"To Sugar Bear Hair,
I met their team at weekend one at Coachella
and they really helped me and my friends out with sister security, because it was CRAZY!
You guys probably already know about
their iconic hair vitamins
But they just came out with
brand new vegan sleep vitamins
And first of all, it's so bomb,
but most importantly, I've been dealing with
a lot of anxiety recently,
and it always comes late at night
when I'm laying in bed thinking
Which is not fun or fresh
So I've been taking these 30 minutes before bed and they've been really really helping
So if you guys want to
check 'em out, you can swipe up."
James Charles is dealing with existential dread,
just take some sleep vitamins
Okay, that's it! That's what caused this whole thing
And that is what caused Tati to go on Instagram and post this big rant about how upset she was
"When you do so much for people in your life and...
they not only don't return the favour,
but they just... don't even see you...?"
So why was this a big deal for Tati?
Well, Tati has her own brand of vitamins,
which are health and beauty vitamins
So for him to not promote his friend's vitamin product and promote some other product
Apparently, she felt very betrayed by this
[crying voice] "I'm just so upset... "
The product that James promoted was for sleeping.
"—with brand new vegan sleep vitamins, and first of all, it's so bomb."
Tati's product is for health and beauty.
Yes, the company does do those type as well,
but he specifically held up the bottle of sleep pills
And that's what he talked about — to sleep
So after Tati made this post on Instagram,
James Charles deleted the post [false]
and apologized, said:
"I want to publicly apologize to my
close friend Tati.
She's been like a mother, and blah.. blah.. blah.. support, and this weekend I did an instagram story for vitamins...
'Cause they helped me with
security at Coachella
I did not accept any money
Tati has a vitamin brand which I take daily. I did not think aboutthe competition, which was a major oversight
I've supported Tati both online and off
like she's done to me
I'm devastated that I hurt someone
that I truly love and have endless respect for
So he deleted the post, didn't take any money,
and apologized
Maybe I'm naïve?
Seems to me like this was an oversight.
From a creator's perspective, I've done this too
A brand does you a favour and you just be like "alright fine" on InstaChat
We're cool now. It's kind of like a throwaway thing
It doesn't seem impossible that this was just a mistake
You know, it seems like the kind of thing
where they could just call each other and resolve this
But according to Tati:
"I want to share with you guys really quickly why I'm being so public about this
'cause I know the first thing a lot of people will say is, "Hey, why didn't you pick up the phone?
Why didn't you message him back?
Like you guys should handle this privately... " "
Right! Why not? I don't get it!
I really don't get it
Let's hear the motivation to why she decided to make
this video to destroy James Charles' career:
"I was planning on hopping in my
car and, you know, sitting down with him,
but... I changed my mind very, very quickly."
She was planning to talk to James,
but she changed her mind... why?
"When I found out that he had been
giving his side to drama channels
He had been in contact with plenty of them
I immediately knew that this was all about damage control, and had little to do with his care for me
because I just don't..."
So basically, she didn't resolve this privately
with James Charles,
because she found out that
he's been talking to drama channels
Something that she admits that she's done as well.
She said she talked to...
"I have spoken with two drama channels
that reached out,
and one of them is 'Here for the Tea'
the other is 'Tea Spill,' um they're... "
So she's spoken to drama channels as well, and this is the reason why she didn't want to talk to James
Well, if you go to one of the drama channels
that she mentions
[Both] "Tea Spill"
They post that James Charles said this:
[reads DM]
[Tati] "I immediately knew that this was all about damage control, and had little to do with his care for me
because I just don't..."
She was mad that he talked to drama channels because she thought he was gonna expose her
This is what he said!
I really don't get it
I'm not here to defend James Charles,
I just don't think what Tati did is that justified
She says how fame changed James Charles and that she's been this mentor figure for him
"Fame, power and a fat bank account
will change almost anyone"
She says she tried to be that person for him
But I think it's worth noting here that Tati is 37 years old
James Charles is still a teenager
Yes, he's 19. Yes, that doesn't excuse his behaviour,
but for a mother "figure" to just completely drag this kid
There's no one — no one has a problem with this?
Over something that could be resolved in private?
I had p... I have plenty of Youtubers being unfair to me, publicly, that has been humiliating
but either we talk it out in private, or I just stop being friends with them
It's not that difficult
I can't imagine just making a video
publicly dragging someone instead of talking to them
Ignoring their calls and just being like,
"I'm gonna drag this person online instead"
It feels very manipulative, this whole thing
Maybe you don't agree with me on that,
but I have a few more points to prove that
And it's how she talks about her brand
If you ask people — what did James Charles do?
People will say, "Oh, he tried to manipulate people about their sexuality."
That was the big drama, right?
But then what has that to do with Tatiana's brand?
"Good enough on its own,
and we're selling like hotcakes.
Like I don't need to at this point.
As we grow, maybe I will.
But that's not where my spend is,
like, I don't —
I not gonna put $100,000 into an Instagram post
for someone to jam a pill in their mouth and smile
that probably isn't taking it...
Uhm, I'd rather put that $100,000 into research,
and creating a really dope product that people really love and that's why they come back for more."
"My product is selling like hotcakes,
I just care about spending money to make
my product as good as possible."
These are... she's... this is mad
"Go with my intuition and to like really, really try to do the right thing and to be a good person
and I know I'm a role model, and that matters to me. That has gravity to me."
"People see me as a good person and I know I'm a role model"
It feels a lot like James Charles bad, me very good
Very good. My brand good, James Charles' bad
"And I want to make a difference,
and let me also share that when I do reach the
level of success that I hope to with Halo,
I'm gonna make a lot of positive changes.
They have huge plans for what I want to do to give back, and I have a... [Felix laughs]
She wants to do good with this brand.
Oh, she has plans for huge changes to
do, a lot of good... then just do it.
Saying you're gonna do good things
means nothing, okay? It's just another thing
It just feels weird to me how everyone
absolutely love her
Look at how many people like this video!
It feels very manipulative.
She's putting herself on a pedestal, while she clearly
was completely fine not outing this behavior
about James Charles essentially
using people's sexuality
And as long as James Charles would have instead promoted her vitamins, she would have been fine with it!
She would not have made this video, she would have been "good boy, James Charles, thank you very much"
All these issues arise just because
it was an opportunity for her to do that.
And I do have a big problem with that.
"And to be a good person and I know I'm a role model, and that matters to me."
And the fact that a lot of people are celebrating this as something positive
because yes, it's fun to drag someone online
It's very troubling to me how this sort of behaviour gets rewarded online. This is 24 million views
For me to be the only one thinking this way,
it feels a bit weird to me
That's why I feel like I have to bring my opinion on this from a Youtuber perspective
James Charles has not been secret about liking straight guys, it's something that he's been spelling out for years!
"Attractive straight boys will be the death of me."
[Ryland] "You have an issue with straight boys"
[James] "I do"
[Ryland] "You need to work it out"
[James] "I'm working on it, girl"
[Ryland] "You have to able to find a masculine gay guy"
[James] I mean there a million of them,
but there is no challenge in that
[Ryland] That's never gonna end in a relationship
[James] Well not with that attitude it won't
[Shane] "If anything, you are just
looking in the wrong places"
[Shane] "Like maybe stop looking at the straight guys"
So people were fine with this until it became a big deal
Until... it's like, oh okay.
NOW everyone stopped following James Charles
Like all these people in the community that are also so controversial have all unfollowed him
I feel like there has to be something else, right?
There has to be something else that James Charles has done that I don't know about that hasn't surfaced yet
because otherwise this just doesn't make sense to me
I'm not saying that I think he is innocent,
I just say they both exposed themselves, in my opinion
So again, according to Tati,
this whole thing started because
Tati thinks that he went through this elaborate stunt at Coachella about security
to make a promo for this vitamin brand on Instagram
And everyone's going, [mocking] "YAAAY TEAAAAAA!"
F*cking cringe... so pathetic, all of you.
That's just my opinion.
I'm Poppy Poopy Pope. Goodbye.
[Pew News music plays]